[музика]
раді вітати вас у цьому випуску Європа У
фокусі Мене звуть ліс шум у Польщі
триває передвиборча кампанія і правляча
націонал консервативна партія може
втратити свою більшість тому частина її
стратегії залучення виборців полягає у
поширенні страхів щодо біженців
а саме щодо тих хто намагається
перетнути кордони з Білорусі до Польщі
тобто потрапити на територію
Європейського Союзу незважаючи на
посилання безпеки кількість нелегальних
перетинів кордону зростає
Тіна пролягає у вздовж кордону між
польським підляським воєводством і
білоруссю але не біженці турбують
місцевих жителів таких як Марія
пшишиховська вона більше стурбована
тоном передвиборчої кампанії яка
розколює суспільство розпалювання
націоналізму таксонофобії усе це може
зашкодити її бізнесу каже Вона і
створити погану репутацію її рідній
Польщі
це може виглядати як світ Після
Апокаліпсису але це всього лише кордон
Європейського Союзу це підляшшя Польща
на кордоні з білоруссю тут майже нічого
немає окрім лісу полів і кількох
будинків і саме тому Марія пшиховська
переїхала сюди 6 років тому вона
побудувала будинок для людей які шукають
тиші із спокою але цього року справи
йдуть доволі кепсько
я розмовляла з друзями і вони сказали що
Хотіли приїхати сюди на велосипедах але
не хочуть зустрічати на кожному кроці
солдатів які запитують Куди вони їдуть і
навіщо і я можу це зрозуміти
ця прикордонна територія між Польщею та
білоруссю знаходиться під особливим
наглядом з моменту російського
вторгнення тут збудовано сучасний паркан
і солдати патрулюють цю територію вони
займаються виявленням контрабандистів і
людей які нелегально перетнули кордон
Польща звинуватила Білорусь в
організації припливу мігрантів до ЄС
через Польщу з метою дестабілізації
регіону через нелегальну міграцію та
присутність російської групи бойовиків
Вагнер у Білорусі тут розміщено близько
10 тисяч солдатів немає сумнівів що
білоруський режим співпрацює з кремлем а
напади на польському кордоні мають на
меті дестабілізувати нашу країну Але Я
переконаний що ці дії не матимуть успіху
завдяки польським військовим та
зміцненому кордону
цей регіон змінився через присутність
військових і паркан довжиною понад 180
кілометрів
це найкраще каже фермер Станіслав
нікевич який живе Всього за 4 кілометри
від кордону
зараз набагато спокійніше раніше був
лише колючий дріт люди могли легко
перетинати кордон А зараз їм доводиться
різати паркан або копати під нього тож
для нас так безпечніше але він каже що з
ним ніколи нічого не траплялося
більшість людей які живуть поблизу
кордону бачили мігрантів які намагаються
потрапити до Європейського Союзу Я
навіть боялася відчиняти вікна тому що
вони кричали і плакали і там були
маленькі діти
маріяховська не поділяє цих страхів
ми не відчуваємо тут загрози Ані від
біженців Ані від групи Вагнера
у мене таке враження що це просто
нагнітання страху для досягнення певної
політичної мети
правляча партія правої справедливість
зосередила свою передвиборчу кампанію на
питаннях безпеки під гаслом безпечне
майбутнє для польського народу і вона
виділила одну із загроз
еміграція нелегальна еміграція
велика кількість людей приїжджає сюди не
для того щоб працювати а для того щоб
скористатися соціальною допомогою
а також для того щоб підірвати нашу
безпеку хтось робиться організовано а
хтось із власних спонукань
постійні застереження щодо нелегальної
міграції та гучні виступи політиків із
військовими представниками не сприяють
місцевому туризму
славомір Дрон каже що у його готелі
кількість бронювань упала на
70-80%. а ресторан часто порожній
це не лише передвиборча кампанія це
довгострокова компанія
змусити людей постійно боятися
змусити їх боятися щоб уряд міг
гарантувати їм безпеку
партія правої справедливість також
вирішила провести референдум у день
виборів і запитати виборців що Вони
думають про політику ЄС щодо надання
прихистку
проморолики і формулювання запитань
радше сугестивні ніж серйозні ви
підтримуєте те щоб тисячі нелегальних
мігрантів з близького сходу та Африки
були прийняті через примусовий механізм
ЄС
Ми кажемо ні нелегальні міграції
Марія псишиховська намагається не
піддаватися впливу цих політичних
настроїв вона не хоче відмовлятися від
своєї справи У яку вклала стільки грошей
і сил вона вважає що люди не повинні
боятися приїжджати сюди
Було б добре якби вони приїжджали і
підтримували місцевий бізнес і таких
людей як ми а також побачили На власні
очі що тут насправді відбувається як це
виглядає зблизька
вона сподівається що до підляшшя
повернеться нормальне життя після
виборів 15 жовтня
24 лютого 2022 року дата яка назавжди
закарбується в пам'яті українців адже
саме цього дня почалося повномасштабне
російське Вторгнення в їхню країну
Але для евніки ця дата особлива ще й
Тому що це є день народження яке ж воно
життя дитини яка бачила свою країну лише
у війні наш кореспондент відвідав нікута
її родину у передмісті Києва щоб
дізнатися
свої дні які будь-яке двадцятимісячна
дівчинка вона ходить у парк і годує
голубів
але ця дівчинка росте в Україні Вона
народилася 24 лютого 2022 року у день
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії вона
ніколи не знала жодного дня Миру коли
тривога вона це саме більше відчуває
Вона даже в дорозі коли в нас получалося
що заставала нас тривога в дорозі і я
переживаю Хоча не панікую ну все одно
внутри переживання я вона
практикається до тебе і просто мучить
Ось це я дивилась даже з перших днів
війни ми їхали з роддому і вони Всю
дорогу даже не плакусіла це
унікальне випадки тому що діти наоборот
коли відчувають тривогу кіпішують вони
допиваються своєї цілі Вона емнічка ні
її сім'я живе у передмісті Києва
Аніта Олександрова вже була у лікарні її
готували до кесаревого розтину коли
почалося вторгнення Росії
о 5 ранку ми почули всі вибухи і сильні
вибухи в мене зрозуміли спочатку що це
але через хвилин 5-10 нам лікар підійшла
і ми це страх говорить ці речі ваші тому
що вас ну почалася війна напевно ми
будемо йти в підвал
того ж дня їй зробили кесарів розтин і
перевели до підвалу який переобладнали
під екстрене укриття
так евніка провела перші сім днів свого
життя під землею
коли бої під Києвом посилилися сім'я
знайшла прихисток у родичів у сільській
місцевості
додому вони повернулися лише тоді коли
російські війська відійшли під Києвом
ми все одно там А серце б'ють тому ми і
вирішили повернутися Ми там відпочили
почали ми трішки від тривог ми трішки
відіспалися
відтоді їхній район повернувся до життя
знову відкрилися кафе і підприємства і
все більше і більше сусідів повертається
зараз усе виглядає майже так як було до
російського вторгнення
треба буде вмиватися
А я я
думаю виходьте мені
топ топ топ топ
але повсякденне життя цієї молодої сім'ї
все що затьмарене війною вони знайшли
квартиру на першому поверсі де
почуваються безпечніше
Олександр Олександров працює у компанії
яка має важливе значення у військовій
справі більше він нічого не може
розповісти
Я чекав цю дитину в нас була на жаль
втрата завмерла дитятко третій три
місяці було
до еніжки тому ми дуже переживали і нам
було
лячно все-таки було що як бути далі що
нарешті ось дитинка і отак от все але
помаленьку
коли вмикається тривога евника та її
батьки ховаються у комірчині і роблять
усе можливе щоб життя доньки було
якомога легшим і без турботнішим
так ще
нки
Yes фізичні національні кордони майже
зникли принаймні для тих людей які мають
правильний паспорт
наприклад у браїль суро Яна
французько-італійському кордоні обидві
країни спільно працюють над створенням
одного спільного привабливого
туристичного регіону але Всього за
кілька кілометрів звідси у місцях
демігранти хочуть перетнути кордон з
Італії до Франції кордон захищений так
як мало дев ЄС
це парадокс відкритого але закритого
кордону який залишає тисячі мігрантів у
невизначеності
Я хочу потрапити до Франції
Франції має бути соромно
це не по-людськи
[музика]
Себастьян олара мер міста брельсьюр
раяна південному сході Франції Бажаю
всього найкращого відвідувачем
туристичного офісу своєї громади місто
збільшені ж двома тисячами населення
розташоване на березі Середземного моря
у прикордонному регіоні між Францією та
Італією
Я шукаю брошури карти та путівник для
нашого проекту алько трагію
Аль котра розшифровується як південні
Альпи Лазурне узбережжя цей проект
Європейського Союзу підтримує
транскордонне співробітництво між
французькими та італійськими
муніципалітетами ще більше стираючи
кордони
ми покладаємося на тісні зв'язки з
Італією найближче доброїлля пляж
знаходиться у ант-мілії віталії
внутрішнім їздимо в лімони це також
Віталій Ми не можемо обійтися без
транспортних зв'язків цей прикордонний
регіон поєднує у собі мальовничі гірські
пейзажі та багато французької
італійської історії до 19 століття Це
був найважливіший торговий шлях з
п'ємонто до Середземномор'я
північна частина долини Роя була
частиною Італії під час Другої світової
війни і кордон був спірним до 1947 року
Сьогодні ці італійські фортеці
занепадають через понад 70 років після
війни тут не залишилося нічого Що
вказувало б на те що тут проходить
французько-італійський кордон Європа без
кордонів
на південь у бік Середземного моря
маршрут веде повстарі митниці та
прикордонні переходи французькі та
італійські і ті і інші уже розвалюються
спочатку митники а потім і прикордонники
зникли з внутрішніх кордонів
Європейського Союзу
паспорти тут більше не перевіряють
принаймні так здається
але за годину їзди на південь на
Середземному морі таке буває лише у
виняткових випадках
протягом багатьох років Франція охороняє
свій кордон між вентимілією в Італії та
ментоном на Лазурному узбережжі
французька прикордонна поліція працює на
внутрішньому пункті перетину кордону
Європейського Союзу деякий час тому
прикордонний пост навіть було розширено
з'явився спеціальний пункт де Франція
може затримувати нелегальних мігрантів
на 24 години
[оплески]
причина біженці та мігранти переважно з
африканських країн
більшість із них дістаються до антимілії
через Середземне море та південну Італію
це не по-людськи
дійсно не по-людськи французам вони не
потрібні ніхто не хоче приймати їх Вони
відправляють їх назад до кордону не
таких як ми а людей які втекли зі своїх
країн і приїхали сюди
на вулицях в інтімілії вже багато років
живуть безхатченки багато з них молодь
вони не втрачають Надії знайти шлях
через кордон
Я хочу потрапити до Франції ви
намагалися перетнути кордон Ні не
намагався
поліція витісняє їх з центру міста
італійський уряд у Римі відмовився
надати державну підтримку цим людям і
звинувачує Францію у їхніх стражданнях
багато хто увиті мільї погоджується із
цим
Франція має бути соромно це
несправедливо
просто кредо кинувся це неправильно Чому
італійці повинні приймати їх усіх
Влада закрила єдиний центр прийому
біженців три роки тому під час пандемії
ковіду побоюючись по ширині інфекції
його роботу Так і не відновили тільки
католицька благодійна організація
Карітас роздає їжу протягом двох годин
вранці надвечір волонтери готують їжу
для безхатченків один із них будівельний
підрядник Філіп поломбардо Він погодився
допомагати протягом року
у середньому щодня до вентимілії
приїжджає від 100 до 150 людей
в інтімілі це лише зупинка на шляху
незважаючи на охорону мігрантам вдається
знову і знову перетинати кордон із
Францією
тут річка Роя впадає у Середземне море у
південних Альпах ця річка приваблює
туристів і любителів піших прогулянок
які французьке містечко брейсюр Royal
[музика]
з 2014 року Європейський союз виділив
цьому прикордонному регіону понад 200
мільйонів євро на розвиток туризму
спільну охорону природи та транскордонне
співробітництво між гірськими громадами
ми створили туристичні брошури
інформаційні таблички та цей веб-сайт
який висвітлює різні громади на
території рої талії та їхні визначні
пам'ятки
один із таких монументів
понад 300 євреїв із усієї Європи які
звідси депортували до освенциму
італійці французи німці голландці
більшість із них тікали від нацистів
спочатку на південь Франції а потім у
гори на італійській стороні і вони
опинилися тут у концентраційному таборі
[музика]
ця виставка покликана спонукати до
роздумів і не лише про депортацію цей
стенд називається відчайдушно втеча
через гори багато місцевих жителів
переховували тут євреї втікачів директор
виставки Роберто бьянко проводить
паралель із сьогодення
Арчі чи домінця Ми забуваємо те що вони
винесли з історії набір цінностей на
яких була заснована наша Європа і саме в
цьому полягає наша людяність коли ми
стикаємося з питаннями міграції
[музика]
у четвер філіппо ломбарду готує обід для
мігрантів на Стоянці у вантімільї він
його дружина Дана та їхні друзі
допомагають раз на тиждень Уже понад пів
року
волонтери обмінюються актуальною
інформацією у текстових повідомлень
зараз у місті багато людей за ретреї
Сомалі та особливо судано
зараз коли у всьому світі йдуть війни в
сім'ї які можуть собі це дозволити
забирають дітей і виїжджають
що нелегальні переправники вже чекають
на біженців на залізничній станції в
антимілії кухарі волонтери намагаються
попереджати мігрантів про цих злочинців
часто вони вже знають з лампи дузи той
коли приїде сюди
Вони знають їхні прізвища і чи є вони
гроші
у цих переправників є лише одна спроба
перевести мігрантів через кордон
використовуючи стежку Біля головної
дороги до Франції про яку знають усі
уветимільє цей маршрут легкодоступний
але небезпечний він веде прямо через
автостраду
перед тим як вирушити в дорогу вони
залишають останні речі сподіваючись що
якщо їх спіймають французькі
прикордонний патруль не знайде нічого що
могло б довести що вони щойно прибули з
Італії
волонтери вже три години готують їжу
разом з мігрантами враховуючи час на
закупівлі та приготування
дуже гостро смачно і гостро багатьом
таке подобається Солоне і гостре
час летить непомітно на Стоянці у місті
інші волонтери готуються розносити їжу
усі волонтери залежать один від одного
я завжди кажу що як люди Ми вже
народжуємося з проблемами
Я теж мігрант італієць але все одно
мігрант
моя мати покинула калабрію на півдні
Італії в 1956 році і приїхала сюди
вона мені завжди казала якщо троє людей
можуть їсти за одним столом то і п'ятеро
і шестеро теж можуть
вечеря подається по буднях о 7:00 вечора
Ми намагаємося зав'язати розмову але
майже ніхто з мігрантів не бажає
говорити на камеру в основному через
страх депортації у ЄС досі діє правило
що біженці та мігранти які прибувають до
ЄС повинні залишатися у тій країні до
якої Вони прибули спочатку тому Багато
хто тут стає дуже настороженим коли його
запитують чи прямує він до Франції
Ні я не збираюся їхати до Франції Я хочу
залишитися тут якщо отримує тут
прихисток
Ви також із судану
Так я сюди
тому ми приїхали сюди
Я б не сказав що ми тут з наміром щось
отримати а просто через небезпеку з якою
Ми зіткнулися в судані
і через вбивства
Ось чому ми приїхали сюди
зазвичай італійська Влада надає
мігрантам відстрочку депортації фактично
дозвіл на тимчасове перебування в Італії
з гуманітарних міркувань
чинне законодавство ЄС Не дозволяє їм
виїжджати до інших країн ЄС Тому цей
кордон важкий для мігрантів але
волонтери не готові з цим змиритися
проблема не в Європі в європейських які
не можуть зрозуміти що краще дати цим
людям який засоби для існування ніж
миритися з тими хто краде з
переправниками саме вони створюють
проблеми мігранти мають право приїжджати
сюди
багато коштів ЄС йде на допомогу
усуненні кордонів у французької
італійських Альпах директор виставки
Роберто бьянко згадує про права людини а
також про уроки та спадщину воїн і
масових депортацій 20-го століття
колись коли Люди бачили тут незнайомці
вони відчиняли двері своїх домів щоб
допомогти сховати і захистити його
своїм прикладом ці люди показали як
можна відновити певний баланс після
такої складної історії
серед мігрантів у вантімілії ходять
чутки про те що десь у горах живуть
місцеві жителі які знають усі таємні
маршрути а іноді і показують
мандрівникам дорогу
Ми живемо в епоху коли це більше людей
замовляють книги онлайн або читають
цифрові копії але як не дивно у
Великобританії збільшилася кількість
книжкових магазинів у столиці
Великобританії Лондоні кілька творчих
людей зібралися разом і відкрили
книжковий магазин на човні це популярне
місце серед книжкових хробаків і вірус
на Сенсація у соціальних мережах
А на сьогодні це все більше історій ви
можете знайти у наших соціальних мережах
Дякуємо за перегляд Бережіть себе і до
зустрічі
[музика]